c'est au moment là je dédicace je le
dédicace à la fin d'émission peut poser
une question le haut de tous ces gosses
et un melon
ouais ah ah yes et là c'est bon
maintenant publicité à il faut du temps
tous égaux à faire une interview ego je
change les filles je change les couches
changer changer choix bien lieu
si vous voulez chanter c'est là dedans
pour vous jacques séguéla est synonyme
de quoi figallo mal est ce que vous
pensez qu'aujourd'hui jacques séguéla
est un grand homme
non ma devise
un con qui marche beaucoup mieux que dix
intellectuels ci at il pourtant je
voudrais taxi compte en banque
audiard est acquis pour govou exactement
il a dit mathieu jusqu'en mai
bah oui le répit à savoir est ce que
vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui jacques
séguéla soit une vraie star non est ce
que vous pensez que le public aime
jacques séguéla et ceux qui aiment la
pub même parce que je me suis tellement
incarner un an tous les moyens possibles
orgue rapport à toutes les portes et à
tous les micros pour l'être que je pense
qu'ils doivent pas m'aimer mais assez
forte montée des fûts du jour c'est tout
ce qui est qu'ils haïssent la pub va pas
évidemment met à la poubelle ils ont mis
les rayons est ce que jacques séguéla
atteint aujourd'hui une certaine
sérénité dans la vie oui ça c'est le
vrai prix village de la gimone avions le
on dit que jacques séguéla il est un des
plus beaux mecs de paris jacques séguéla
on pense quoi tous les matins ma femme
oui si la vente on ne fait pas ça change
et de femmes
on a compris on dit comme tu es beau et
je me précipite devant la gazette du spa
c'est un miracle à tour et j'ai dû
perdre 50 balais les biceps ont dû
revenir et puis je vois devant la glace
que je suis allée b a maintenant le dk
tikva pillon julienne ont créé eux mêmes
parce qu'elle est amour aveugle et
l'histoire est vraie et je téléphonais
femme très belle et j'ai eu la chance à
est vraiment celle à combien de chaînes
c'est la troisième est la première c'est
une grande salle la seconde j'ai été
marié cinq heures ah oui oui c'est
beaucoup 5
je sentais que c'était une bêtise à toi
que j'ai dit je vais dire non devant le
maire don cherry
j'étais là devant le maire il y avait
les bleus mes parents mes beaux parents
les copains j'ai vraiment dit oui les
sorties non alors moi j'ai filmé puis il
lâche ses plus beaux jours de ma vie bon
un peu et à 4 heures du matin quand la
fête a été terminée jeudi écoute je
crois que je me suis ton qu'elle je vais
te dire non j'ai pris deux gifles tu
allé coucher à l'hôtel je vais revue
devant le juge mais dans ces cas là on
paie une pension alimentaire
on fait ce qu'il faut quand on est un
chef de l'état déjà tellement est ce que
jacques séguéla n'en a pas marre qu'on
lui parle sans arrêt de françois
mitterrand alors que jacques séguéla a
fait beaucoup plus pour la france
non mais c'est mon second père françois
mi-temps d'abord c'est lui qui a fait de
moi un homme de gauche parce que je ne
sais même pas ce qu'était la droite et
la gauche verts y compris à la politique
et puis tout le monde et dit que c'était
moi qui avait fait dire à françois
mitterrand mais entre nous c'est lui qui
m'a sacré roi de la publicité petit roi
ni roi quand même pas la force on quitte
c'était pas mal hein le coût du clocher
pétainiste et où là c'était assez
marrant on y revient
il est génial parce qu'il a la modestie
et gothique l'un extraordinaire sans
être modeste qui te king c'est mitterand
qui a fait de moi un petit roy we saw
mais est-ce que vous pensez que jacques
séguéla laissera une trace dans
l'histoire de france
non mais on va revenir à meilhan un jour
j'ai demandé à mitterrand monsieur le
président qu'est ce qui fait courir
françois mitterrand c'est pas le genre
de question
ghyvelde quoi c'est un peu et il m'a dit
moi je voudrais que le jour où je
quitterai cette maison nous étions à
l'elysée la france un petit peu
différente de ce que je les trouvais en
entrant et que j'y sois un petit peu
pour quelque chose mais moi je voudrais
que le jour où je quitterai la pub à 90
en 2022 parce qu'ils ont huit ans c'est
le grand-père a entrepris connivence de
moi je voudrais que le jour où je
quitterai la pub elle soit un petit peu
différente
ce soit fait beaucoup pour la pub ça
c'est clair non c'est vrai mais il a pu
mener que la pub
1 j'ai cru au début tout est là les
sauver le monde j'ai cru que maire
jeanney dit des conneries
bon ben voilà même sort à la barre qui
peut-on comparer jacques séguéla ben
ardisson qui ferait rester dans la pub
voit ses jambes fuselées
on pousse les anversois
j'en passe et l'éditeur l'américaine
je suis
à